un pequeño pero horrible extraterrestre
está en la punta de la torre eiffel que
mide 324 metros de alto y amenaza
destruir toda la ciudad de parís
un agente de los 'hombres de negro' se
encuentra al nivel del suelo a 54 metros
de distancia de la torre eiffel
apuntando su arma láser al
extraterrestre a qué ángulo debe la
gente disparar su arma láser redondea el
resultado a dos lugares decimales de ser
necesario si construimos un triángulo
rectángulo con estos datos vamos a tener
que la altura de la torre eiffel es de
324 metros aquí se encuentra el malvado
extraterrestre y el hombre de negro se
encuentra a 54 metros de distancia de la
torre eiffel a nivel del suelo y tenemos
que estar apuntando a su arma láser al
extraterrestre realmente lo que nos
están preguntando aquí es cuál es este
ángulo de aquí que vamos a llamar teta
nos están dando el lado opuesto de este
ángulo y nos están dando también el lado
adyacente este de aquí para encontrar el
ángulo necesitamos usar una función
trigonométricas
recordar las escribimos nuestro de
mónico
acá
todas
ese no es el lado opuesto entre la
hipotenusa nosotros necesitamos
relacionar el lado opuesto con el lado
adyacente el cos en ese lado adyacente
entre la hipotenusa tampoco nos sirve y
la tangente es el lado opuesto entre la
do adyacente esta si no sirve podemos
decir que la tangente del ángulo teta es
igual al lado opuesto que mide 324
metros entre el lado adyacente que mide
54 metros pero lo que queremos conocer
es este ángulo teta el ángulo que al
obtener su tangente nos de 324 entre 54
aquí vamos a necesitar una calculadora
para usar la función de tangente inversa
reescribimos esto como tangente inversa
también escrita como tangente a la menos
de la tangente del ángulo theta igual a
la tangente inversa de esta operación
324 entre 54 este tangente inverso de
324 entre 54 lo que nos va a dar como
resultado un ángulo que al sacar su
tangente nos de 324 entre 54 y esta
parte de tangente inversa de la tangente
de teta nos dice cuál es el ángulo que
ha sacar su tangente me da tangente de
teta que es el ángulo así que esto es
ángulo teta igual la tangente inversa de
324 entre 54 de nuevo esta tangente
inversa puede confundir es un poco pero
simplemente es el ángulo al que al
obtener su tangente nos da este valor
324 entre 54
sacamos nuestra calculadora nos
aseguramos que estén grados no en
radiales en grados para poder obtener
esta operación y buscamos nuestra
tangente inversa así que es 324 entre 54
y este resultado le sacamos la tangente
inversa y nos da 80.500 37 etcétera
nos dicen que redondeamos a dos lugares
decimales así que será 80 puntos 54 el
ángulo al que tiene que ser disparada el
arma láser es de 80 puntos 54 grados y
así podremos vencer a ese horrible
extraterrestre